all right there was excitement
nervousness a variety of motion emotions
for
families here at ok adcock in the
northwest
part of the valley and of course the
school they had their designated areas
for
each mode of transportation as the
hybrid cohort a arrived here on campus
now here's a look at what it looked like
this morning as families arrived
crossing guards were in place to help
walking families arrive safely
to keep traffic moving in front of the
school parents pulled into the main
entrance to drop off their students
and exit on the opposite side then at
the bus drop off kids were socially
distant
as they waited outside we're told each
school had their own version of drop-off
and lunch distribution
implementing what was best for their
school community students and parents
told us how they feel about the return
to the classroom i feel
excited that i'm back to school i can
see all my friends
yeah he was excited to get back into
school and seeing people
and his friends again and yes just
building those connections again i think
it's good for them
so yes i'm excited that they're actually
back in the classrooms because it's been
it's it's hard for first and third
graders to be
online all day
so the parents we spoke with say the
drop-off process was easy to understand
and they even told us that it was
smoother than what they're used to on a
regular school day in the past
now the hybrid cohort b their first day
will be on march
4. reporting from the northwest part of
the valley at hyde and torrey pines
bianca holman 8 news now